hello everyone and welcome to what could
be the funniest Evans gambit game ever
played that well at least when when at
least one of the players is a master is
involved it's a frame Frank James
Marshall against Samuel Shapiro now we
don't know who similar Shapiro was
supposedly he was a 17 year old high
school student but that's pretty much
all the information we have so there's
the hoodie guy again and in honor of the
hoodie guy of course I am wearing the
hoodie so it's a game from 1944 the game
went the year when Frank James Marshall
died but I don't know when this game was
played exactly we do know that it was it
was well II in or before March of 1944
but we're gonna get back to that after
we check out the game so without further
ado 17 year old high school student vs.
6 67 year old Frank James Marshall so
let's check it out
we have E 4 E 5 Bishop to c4 so the
bishops opening we will kind of
transpose into the Evans gambit Bishop
c5 and now b4 we're the ship captures on
b4 c3 Russian goes back Bishop to a5 and
now Knight to f3 and nice the c6 Shapiro
basically transposes into the Evans
gambit the mainline we have castles by
Marshall ending up d6 just continuing
development and not be for now which is
always the case you want to start giving
up material for really rapid development
Bishop back to b6 not the greedy for
pawns and now instead of D captures on
e4 we have a 4 now a 4 if you check the
database or at least the one I'm using
it says that the last time a four was
played was in 1905 but since this is a
game from 19 1944 and it is a
simultaneous exhibition game perhaps it
isn't well it doesn't seem to be in the
database but okay we have a four and now
Knight to f6
Sharpedo continuous development attacks
the e4 pawn and now a5 so what's the
point behind a5 let's check it out
Shapiro captures the pawn we have Knight
captures an a5 and Marshall captures
that rook captures an a5 Bishop
characters on a5 and only now D
characters on a5
attacking the night here we have D
captures and now Knight captures on e5
so attacking the f7 pawn and here Frank
James Marshall manages to Bluff his way
away from from the Queen trade because
Queen captures on d1 is still the best
choice for black it doesn't matter
you'll capture on f7 but after King g7
and rook captures you're gonna play
Bishop b6 prepare c5 so you can block
Bishop e3 check and the White has
nothing well let's say Bush base recheck
c5 and here you don't have really have
any good continuation you're just down
the exchange so this would have been
best for a4 Shapiro but you know he's
playing Frank James Marshall and he
trusts him so he goes Bishop to e6 he
defends against the threat we have
Bishop characters and e6f captures on e6
and now Queen to b3 attacking the e6
pawn but also the b7 pawn so Bishop to
b6 now defending and also puts pressure
on DF to pawn it prevents f4 but now
Bishop to a3 not going for Queen
captures doesn't really do anything
black angela block with the Queen
instead Bishop to e3 not allowing black
the castle so c5 you want to prevent
this and now Queen to b5 with check now
that c6 is no longer possible with King
to f8 and now f4 so kind of kind of
seems like a risky decision but you know
c4 doesn't really do anything for the
moment so Queen to c7 just adding
another defender to the pawn here and
also if if f5 is played or something you
can just pick up the night so here
Knight the d2 why it starts to bring you
more pieces into the game and not rook
to d8 just developing threatening to
pick up the night on D - well night D
and C for now bringing the knight closer
to the action also just preparing to
eliminate the bishop on b6 and now comes
Knight captures a need for this pawn was
hanging for a few moves now but black
wanted to develop a few pieces before
capturing it so Knight captures a need
for now and here marshal just continues
pushing we have f5 so what do you do
here now Shapiro captures we have he
captures on f5 rook captures on f5 and
here the best idea of
Black is just Knight to f6 you block in
the game continues however after this
route captures an f5 a Shapiro played
King to g8 and here he allows white some
very interesting ideas so feel free to
pause the video and try to find it the
best move for white in this position
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on being well a very
precise calculator as it's not not easy
to find and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's night captures and b6 point being
that you do not want the night captured
well especially not with the Queen since
the Queen is essential to guard the f7
square but for example if Queen captures
you just deliver this check and there's
really not much you can do if you you
can start giving up some pieces but
mainly it's just going to f7 may so best
after Knight captures and b6 is first
group d1 check then white blocks with
the rook you cannot go to f2 denied
covers that rook captures king or queen
characters even better just Queen
captures again you cannot capture due to
the mate on f7 but now just a capture
Sun b6 however you have Queen the c-4
with check and now after the King moves
you pick up the knight and also you
guard your own knight on e5 and now it's
two pieces against the rook that still
undeveloped Brooke white will be much
better here
so after this King to g8 move definitely
Knight characters freeing up this
diagonal for the Queen is best for
marshal however marshal played Queen to
b3 instead he is now threatening some
very nasty discoveries but there is a
one good very very good defensive move
for young Shapiro so feel free to pause
the video again and try to find the well
the only good defensive move for black
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations I'm calculating
precisely all the nasty discoveries
because there aren't any that are really
nasty and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's actually g6
you free the g7 square for the king so
now all the nasty discoveries you can
just move the king but there aren't any
that are good so basically if you
capture the knight doesn't really do
anything because just c4 you block it
and
well next move you can just pick up the
night it doesn't really matter you can
pick up the rook so nothing really
happens here what you can do however
instead of capturing it is also rook to
f7 how about this also doesn't work
because here okay you attack the Queen
you get the rock out of harm's away but
now you have Queen captures on e5
another temporary Queen sacrifice and
after the Knight captures and now you
just play c4 and now you deliver check
and you pick up the Queen so here if you
don't want to give up the Queen for
nothing you have to pick up the bishop
and after let's say rook d1 check first
you trade off a few more pieces of rook
f1 characters captures now you pick up
the Queen and now you are again you know
completely winning in game because you
are up in the exchange so that being
said after Queen to b3 g6 the only good
move for young shapiro however again we
have a we have a twist
Sharpedo finds Knight to d2 and it comes
with a with a similar idea but again it
doesn't work now it works in the game
but it doesn't really work because here
had marshal played Queen to a2 it just
prevents black from surviving this
because now without the Queen being mb3
you will not have the c4 check attacking
the Queen which was crucial in all of
the defensive lines for black so here if
you try g6 or something like that just
not capture some v6 with check and you'l
and you pick up a free piece you know
even if you block with c4 it doesn't
come with the attack on the Queen so
there's really nothing you just move the
knight Knight bd7
and the game continues with white is up
material however after Knight - D -
Frank James Marshall actually captures
the knight with Knight captures and E -
and here a 17 year old high school
student
Samuel Shapiro please c4 and now it's
check and the queen is under attack
Frank James Marshall loses the Queen so
he doesn't want to give it up for
nothing he plays Queen captures and b6
we have Queen captures with check King F
1 and now Queen to III and now with
black being up so much material he will
definitely try not to make him any
mistakes so here you're just attacking a
lot of pieces and it's very hard for
white to defend if y try something like
Knight D captures on c4 you have just
ripped a d1 with meat on the other hand
if you try something like
this Knight captures unseen 490
captaincy for them queen d3 check picks
up the rook on f5 also not very very
good for white so here marshal played
Bishop to e7 attacks the rook also he's
hoping for Brook characters and rook to
f8 mate but you know such it's too late
for for such cheapos here Queen captures
and e2 was played okay we have no stroke
after sandy eight Queen captures and now
it's a queen against a rock and the
knight of course completely winning for
Shapiro Marshall continued with the g4
but with a five and this is the worst
you're playing against the weaker
opponent you're Frank James Marshall and
your opponent just plays a five
basically he says yeah you should resign
this it is the worst feeling in the
world so Marshall continued for a few
more moves g5 with Queen to d1 check now
forcing the King to the second rank and
after king f2 just Queen to c2 check now
this connects to the rook King g3 was
played and after Queen captures on f5 at
Frank James Marshall resigned the game
unmoved 31 now I read I read online that
this is a game from 19 1944 simultaneous
exhibition that Frank James Marshall
held and the result of his simultaneous
exhibition was 17 wins six draws and
only one lost seventeen year-old Samuel
Shapiro and it also says that it's a
loss to the 17 year old Samuel Shapiro
attending Townsend Harris Hall in Queens
New York so perhaps if you are you know
from Queens maybe maybe you know a
certain Samuel Sapiro that is around 75
years old and if so it could be the
gentleman that defeated Frank James
Marshall in this simultaneous exhibition
if he's still alive but 75 is not that
that you know to too much so he could
very well still be alive and you know he
just might be your neighbor you know so
you might have a neighbor who defeated
Frank James Marshall that would be that
would be really awesome so yeah yeah
like I said it's a I don't know when the
game exactly was played since Marshall
died in 1944 in November but it says
that here the Brooklyn daily eagle the
magazine the this game was published the
30th of March on page 15 so
I was definitely played prior to that
not really sure when but just wanna just
thought you guys might enjoy this as
well I swam I thought you might enjoy
this since we're waiting for the world
wrapped in a blaze championship to start
on the 26th so we're gonna check up on
such a few nice games yeah I like this
one and of course you know christmas is
coming so why not give the hoodie guy a
nice victory against none other than
Frank James Marshall so that's the game
I do hope you enjoy that I would like to
thank kuru chess club and Norman our
Fisher Navin kata Krishna s Francoise
John and Jack Coburn for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and well we're preparing for
our next big saga but also first we have
to check underworld rapid embolus
championship so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day